I need an Avenger offworld dr. strange
unavailable chat tomorrow don't invoke
her tonight hi everyone its charlie I
had a chance to see spider-man far from
home this week so this is gonna be my
early non-spoilery reaction in review if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos it's gonna be crazy this summer
there's a new round of that imax ticket
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a
spider-man comment on the video yes I
will address the new cut of Avengers
endgame at the end of this video -
because it was a whole bunch of
announcements in the last couple of days
all really good stuff for Marvel fans
Kevin Feige was even talking about how
Sony was planning on crossing venom over
with spider-man and how that would work
but just to start with spider-man far
from home has this impossible task as a
movie being sandwiched right between
Marvel phase 4 and avengers endgame
probably one of the best last movies in
a big saga of films that anyone has ever
done it's gonna be really hard for any
other movies this summer to do good
against Avengers end game there's still
couple big ones coming later this summer
but just in terms of what it did with
the characters Avengers endgame was such
a final movie for a lot of big stories
that is sort of like Avengers infinity
war and ant-man and the wasp ant-man and
the wasp just like a really small movie
happening sandwiched between two big
Avengers movies so unless you're a
really big hardcore Marvel fan a lot of
people just bound up ignoring that
movies so a lot of people were worried
about spider-man far from home happening
so close to Avengers endgame but the
crazy thing is is they totally nailed it
it's so much better than spider-man
homecoming but the way Kevin Feige
in the Sony people wound up winning was
not in going bigger necessarily it was
actually in going smaller in terms of
stories a very simple story it's all
about spider-man being torn between what
he knows he has to do and what he wants
to do very classic spider-man story
that's what the spider-man character is
all about going back to the classic
comics he's a friendly neighborhood
spider-man he wants to have regular
relationships with his friends or his
love interest depending on which of his
love interests you Stan but all the
while within the context of the MCU you
have Nick Fury saying it's time to step
up the world needs a new Iron Man is
that going to be you even the cops on
the street as you've seen in the
trailers are asking him are you gonna be
the new Iron Man you're gonna be a next
Iron Man now well no I don't have time
I'm too busy doing your jobs I'm kidding
I'm kidding look keep up the good work
because I am going on vacation and for a
lot of the movie he just keeps
deflecting the question refusing the
hero's call I don't have time to do that
when I'm so busy doing your guys jobs
it's been a lot of fun watching
spider-man grow up in the MCU Tom
Holland also growing up before our eyes
I think he was still 18 or 19 when they
cast him as spider-man before Captain
America Civil War and now he's about 23
years old so he's literally growing up
before our eyes but they've also been
using the spider-man character to
broaden the MCU mythology over these
last couple of films and give you this
perspective that we've never got before
which is a regular kid growing up in the
MCU think about all these big Avengers
events and all these battles that they
fight then eventually he gets the spider
bite he becomes spider-man and he
becomes part of the action himself there
was even a trailer yesterday where he
names Mysterio in Avenger welcome to The
Avengers because I guess he's the only
one on planet earth right now that's
available but because he's been such a
fanboy obviously spoilers for Avengers
endgame if you haven't seen it yet
because we have to talk about the end of
that movie he's there on the battlefield
they have the reverse infinity war
moment where iron man was cradling him
while he turned to dust mr. stark I
don't feel so good I don't want to go
they flipped that on his head so he's
left with all this PTSD and trauma and
one of the big complaints about a lot of
the Marvel especially comic book films
is that they don't always deal with the
consequences of some of these really big
actions so like how do they carry this
moment forward how does everybody feel
about the end of Avengers endgame what's
going on in everyone's heads because
it's 2023 all these kids from spider-man
far from home are coming back from the
dust there were so many questions about
how they're going to address that how
are all this classmates the same age
don't worry no spoilers but they do
address that during the movie there are
a lot of theories after Avengers end
game came out how that would work they
have a relatively simple way of
answering that but the script also does
a really good job of honoring the trauma
that spider-man is going through part of
the reason why he wants to go on this
class trip and not be spider-man for the
summer like I just want to have a break
from all this stuff I've been dealing
with but like I said the movie is all
about spider-man being torn between what
he wants to do and what he
needs to do what the world demands of
him and Nick Fury representing the world
time for you to step up whatever he
thought about Tom Hollands performance
during spider-man homecoming I feel like
he's matured a lot as an actor the last
couple of years so he did a really good
job with the dramatic moments they're a
couple of minor complaints that people
will probably have about some of the
jokes that don't quite land there is a
lot of comedy there is a lot of that
teenage romance subplot so if you were
not a fan of that during spider-man
homecoming they do have more of that
during this because they're trying to
develop the spider-man MJ relationship
does you've seen in all the trailers the
costume was great for the costume party
she knows I told her to their credit
they do try to provide a new spin on the
spider-man MJ relationship as you've
seen through Zendaya's performance she's
just a little bit more clever she's the
one that figures out that he's
spider-man and all the trailers speaking
of which he probably seen the last
couple of trailers they've been a lot of
scenes of spider-man swinging around New
York City with Zendaya's MJ and I feel
like one thing that they have done way
way better with the recent spider-man
films is nailed the physics of
spider-man this sort of baletta kmen
through the air that's really hard to do
unless you have amazing special effects
or just really banger practical effects
really easy way to think about that as
like the big final battle from avengers
endgame or the d aging technology how
good has that gotten in the last couple
of Marvel movies is almost getting
flawless you almost can't tell the
difference they could probably even do
an entire film with an 80s version of
The Avengers just D aging these older
MCU heroes to their younger selves as is
with all the previous spider-man stuff
we've seen in the MCU he's very tied to
the Iron Man character as he's dealing
with all this trauma of losing him the
movie does a really good job of adding a
lot of complexity to the legacy of Iron
Man in the MCU so in a broader sense the
world is wondering who's gonna be the
next Tony Stark Iron Man person the
person to wrap the world in a suit of
armor to be this great protector and
sacrificed himself for everyone
spider-man thinks that it's gonna be
this new Mysterio person that's just
shown up wow he seems like he knows what
he's doing maybe I can still be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man but
also think about the negative way that
they've treated the legacy of Iron Man
in the MCU like Avengers age of Ultron
is a good way where you have Scarlet
Witch and vision who grow up hating Tony
Stark because their home was destroyed
their parents were killed with weapons
from Stark Industries the more
hated side of Tony Stark's legacy in the
MCU so even though they're not really
explicit about it a lot of those
questions are raised during these
trailers that you guys have been
watching they deal with that in a really
cool way during the movie Jake
Gyllenhaal was amazing as Mysterio if
you remember the story about Kevin Feige
talking to Keanu Reeves for every single
Marvel movie because Keanu Reeves is
blowing up right now you're all
breathtaking Kevin Feige recently said
when people asked him about Keanu Reeves
oh we talked to him about coming into
every single Marvel movie we're just
waiting for the right role for him
they're still talking to him about the
Eternals right now he said the same
thing about Jake Gyllenhaal we've been
talking to Jake Gyllenhaal about being
in a Marvel movie ever since we started
making Marvel movies at Marvel Studios
the reason why it's taken this long to
get him into the MC is because they just
haven't found a role till they got to
Mysterio just perfect role for the kind
of complex characters that Jake
Gyllenhaal has been playing the last
several years they're also bringing it
full circle by putting him in a
spider-man film - if you remember way
back during the Tobey Maguire era during
spider-man 2 when they were getting
ready to start making that Tobey Maguire
was almost replaced with Jake Gyllenhaal
as the Peter Parker character you think
the Mysterio would be ridiculous in an
MCU movie but they totally make it work
they totally made the fishbowl
everything about the character work he
also layers his scenes as Mysterio in
really cool complex ways that'll stand
out when you go see the movie more than
once so we're just fun to watch Mysterio
in the MCU the first time but the second
time you'll notice way more stuff going
on in scenes than you may have noticed
the first time because you're not really
thinking about the big twists of the
character the only real issues that I
had with the movie is that there are a
couple of jokes that wind up landing
really really flat that they lead on
pretty hard and if you're not a fan of
the teenage romance subplot with the
Peter Parker character in the MCU they
do lean on that pretty hard during this
movie
Sam Jackson is awesome as always as Nick
Fury it shouldn't even be a question at
this point
[ __ ] you've been to space he's the one
that's giving spider-man the
call-to-action telling him to grow up
time to be responsible now the movie
itself also does a lot of world
building for Marvel phase four so not
only is it a really cool take on a
spider-man story in the character it's
also important for the future of the MCU
that being said there are two
post-credit scenes they are important
and they will blow your mind so no
spoilers but be sure to stay through the
end of the credits obviously we'll be
talking about a lot of stuff when the
movie comes out I'm not ready to call it
my favorite spider-man movie so far but
it is up there with spider-man 2 from
Tobey Maguire era I will do a full
ranking of spider-man films once I have
a chance to see it again we're not
really allowed to post our full reviews
til the end of the month so don't worry
I will do a full review when we get
closer to the movie actually coming out
leave all your spider-man video requests
in the comments below I'll probably do a
separate video about what Kevin Feige
said about future venom crossover
because it also has ramifications for
the future of spider-man in the MCU it's
all good news so don't worry about that
and yes I will do a separate video about
the extended cut of Avengers endgame
that they're releasing in theaters next
weekend that's right
releasing endgame in theaters again with
extra footage to get everyone to come
see it so that they can beat avatars box
office I see what you're doing there
Kevin Feige but congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video aliens art please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for that brand
new spider-man far from home extended
trailer with a couple extra big scenes
including that big Avengers moment and
click here for that brand-new Avengers
endgame deleted scene with Iron Man and
Doctor Strange thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]